Je
vous ai été embauché pour représenter les États-Unis comme une
lueur d'espoir en tant que représentants de nos
aspirations les plus élevées qui protégeront l'
état de droit là où l'anarchie
sévit Je suis désolé, nous sommes juste ici J'ai
entendu dire que la nourriture était vraiment super
envie  pour le ramener à la maison 3000 ce qui se
passe ici je ne sais pas ce
qui vous arrive je vous promets que vous pouvez arrêter
ces hommes la promesse cela implique toutes
sortes de ressortissants d'hiver des
officiers militaires aux diplomates tout le
personnel international a l'immunité
ils peuvent être poursuivis vous  n'avez pas de
rapport de police vous devez enquêter
là-dessus il a parlé à qui vous voulez
ils n'écoutent pas vous êtes seul
ce qui s'est passé le dieu a dû
nous suivre avez-vous dit à quelqu'un de
vous regarder faire mieux de fermer votre
bouche c'est  un vieil ami Peter Ward
affaires internes croyez que vous n'êtes pas en sécurité des
accidents se produisent nous avons besoin d'un véhicule de
sécurité blindé qu'est-ce qu'ils font ça
ne vous regarde pas
pourquoi voulez-vous vous débarrasser d'elle je ha  ve
pour protéger cette organisation on vous a
ordonné de quitter cette mission peu
importe pour qui je travaille je ne laisserais
personne s'en tirer avec ça
les commandants militaires de haut niveau
tirent votre père nous avons un système
qui fonctionne ici oh vraiment pour  qui
veulent généralement aller de l'avant s rayonnent les yeux
ouverts d'accord
je ne veux pas de scandale je fais juste mon
travail
toi